my trick was in Virginia Tech around
1998 me and Pharrell who is from
Virginia Beach
we made this phenomenal racket called
super dog and for some reason Newport
News kept booking me and this is a bad
hood like this I mean god bless people
Newport News whereas they said that if I
but what I'm saying this is the hood of
the hood in Virginia's and Parral he
just wasn't a street guy he didn't know
how to get weed he didn't know how to
get I'm saying so I would always wind up
somewhere around Newport News be hearing
about Michael Vick in Virginia Tech and
me hearing how I mean that whole state
was just behind him
it was just his movements it was just
his attitude it was a swagger
it just all identified with us we had
other black quarterbacks what we didn't
have quarterbacks where we were like he
reminds us of us I'm not sure how many
times like a guy from behind him was
about ready to sack him and also needs
coming out there and running for a first
thought of thunder how did he know that
God was back there Michael Vick became a
common name that most people would know
but I think became a name in the college
football world it was like what we see
now with Steph Curry's jump shot it's
just the flick of the wrist I remember
he's throwing a post pattern about 55
yards and it looked like it was on a
rope it was nonchalant it was flawless
it was no effort at all tight spiral
right on the money
and I'm just looking like wow that's
amazing I've never seen anything like
that well Michael Vick went to Virginia
Tech this to me the notion of the black
quarterback was still a rare entity hey
michael vick was frequently called the
greatest athlete to ever play the
position at that time and he might have
been
I was pissed off but my excitement was
wow look this is the guy that should
have been in the in the orange or blue
but I was excited because here's a guy
that I got a chance to get to know seems
the progression of where he's at and the
plan that national championship anybody
in Florida State I mean he came onto the
scene like no other like I've never seen
that from a young quarterback I was a
rookie I Green Bay and he has the
spotlight and all of a sudden they plan
a national championship against Florida
State I can't believe I don't like get
some idea this is unbelievable he's
about to beat the team by self
and he did things athletically that you
just weren't accustomed is seeing at the
quarterback position so that made people
stop the combination of what he looked
like and and black skin and that kind of
talent just make people stop with the
attention
I was this again he was nest full of
black fur every there in the piggy when
he came up to Syracuse I think we had a
conversation that week of just you
should be on the other side but I just
couldn't get over it why it had to
happen to us
you know he sealed the deal with using
his legs and I don't care nobody say he
was one of the fastest I've seen at that
position stunned how sheer at the
carrier don't I just broke $55 off a big
blue leg right made the fake came
running in and beat the whole defense
for speeding one of my best players that
Ryan did solidified to the public that
great athlete this kid they want to like
out
I don't know what revolutionizes to
position me so changing the game was one
thing I was just playing you know I
didn't know what I was doing when Mike
first got drafted I actually went to the
draft that you he was scheduled to go
through New Orleans to work out what a
training I had got traded to New Orleans
Saints and it was a perfect opportunity
for him and I to bond and I was like
look man this is what we've been doing
we're going to talk about life skills so
I think a long-term you know I think
about things that matter so it was kind
of a hard shared the crack because you
know I'm trying to say one thing to him
he's thinking another and so although he
heard me but I don't think he heard the
stopping that I got you know when I was
young I didn't prepare for it you know
everything happens so fast as just dealt
with the way I grew up you know I was
taught not to trust a lot of people so
it takes a lot to gain my trust you know
I just started to see life in a
different different form and you know it
was fun it was Robert you know I had a
great time you know throughout all those
years and you know expression when I got
to Atlanta
right off the top going down to Green
Bank winning that first playoff game at
the age of 22 and not too many people
believing in us from what happened my
rookie year so my second year the
development and the growth was uncanny
sacrifice I see a kid that that was
trying to learn an offense and getting
better than at offense but still
understanding his talents still
understanding how he could take over a
game and that's rare you don't see a lot
of guys coming into the game thinking
I'm gonna win this game it should be a
starter at a young age you really don't
you know understand the magnitude of it
was a remarkable time it was a great
opportunity and also that the NFC
Championship game in 2004 which was a
major accomplishment
you